it's the revolution changing the art  world nfts are a part of our life now  for better or from salvador dali to  pablo picasso to  board apes nfts or non-fungible tokens  exist on an unalterable blockchain which  is basically a magical internet thing  that no one can explain these ain't your  grandma's jpegs as we like to say meet  ryan david fraud crypto investor and nft  enthusiast what makes nfts so appealing  artists online can finally make money  off of their work anyone can succeed  it's very democratic we spoke to one  such artist ourselves how much money  have you made selling nfts i'm nothing  but a lot of people who stole my art  made a lot of money so you got paid in  exposure  sounds like a win-win to me that's  absolutely not what i'm saying art very  much in the eye of the beholder  [Music]